this is what I find interesting like so
you were actually about to quit acting
right before you got shits Creek right
yes just before shits Creek things were
quite bleak my house had just burnt down
I had like three dollars in my bank
account things were I hadn't worked in
close to two years I had just blown my
very first screen test like blown it
blown it blown it blown it and I was I
found myself crying in the Pacific Ocean
a very snotty cry and the universe it
was like don't do this anymore this is
not for you and but then two days later
I got the audition for shits Creek
[Applause]
because a lot of people wouldn't tell
they and I think it's really cool
because be I do have friends that are
actors and it's it's a very hard job
it's either you're like really winning
or you're just like really gone like you
know it's kind of an same thing of music
but it's it's just really cool they are
open about it like because everybody
goes through those moments really like
oh my gosh like is this or should I move
on or should I do this
yeah and I love that you're open about
it I also love that you're hilarious and
one of my favorite shows of all time
yeah it's so it's so great I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this